Yes we finally have a confirmation that
Apple's iPhone 15 lineup is launching at
an Apple event next month on either
September 12th or 13th it's not going to
get delayed until October thankfully
which means we only have one month left
to go now this was actually confirmed by
Apple themselves during their stock
earnings release last week where they
said they're expecting a big jump in
iPhone orders in this current quarter
which actually ends at the end of
September which means apple is basically
telling us they are going to have the
new iPhone 15 launch in September no
delays now there is a chance that the
actual delivery date of at least one of
the Pro Models is getting delayed until
October but I'm actually gonna have to
disagree for one big reason so in this
video I'm gonna go through five new
iPhone 15 updates that you absolutely
must hear if you're planning on
upgrading so let's jump right right into
number one which is a huge report that
confirms why I disagree on the pro model
delay reports update 1 is actually a
really big and important update about
the chip yield of tsmc's brand new three
nanometer chip technology and apparently
it's doing very very well up to 80
percent yield right now which is a lot
better than the previous report that was
actually very worrying of only 55 yield
and that's so terrible that we all
thought we're going to be getting these
delays but they have improved it and on
top of that it's also been said that
tsmc is now going to be covering the
cost of Chip defects for Apple which is
going to save Apple a ton of money and
of course they're only doing this
because apple is their number one
customer and they're making deals to
make them happy and improve Apple's
profit margins to ensure that they can
keep ordering chips every single year
and this is going to be huge for the a17
bionic because apple is going to be way
ahead of the competition with only Intel
starting to order three nanometer chips
potentially next year nobody else but
now getting into update number two this
is a big one that happened over the
weekend we've started to see a bunch of
leaked iPhone 15 Pro cases from actual
multiple sources with different case
manufacturers making them and they
confirm something great first of all all
the cases look great they have Max
they've built in with huge camera bumps
they look very similar except for one
major detail these new cases have
something else instead of a cutout for
the mute switch there's a new button
built for the additional action button
that's coming to the Pro Models only now
of course we've heard a lot about the
action button before it's basically
going to replace the mute switch and
it's going to make it a lot more useful
because some people they just leave it
on silent forever they don't even touch
it it's basically just sitting there
useless for no reason but now you're
going to be able to customize this new
button and make it do various things
like for example we actually had a leak
with an iOS 17 beta code about some of
the options that apple is going to allow
you to do like for example you can
launch a shortcut you can open the
translate app open the camera take
photos open Voice Memos you can use it
of course as a mute switch enable Focus
modes enable accessibility options
enable the magnifier or the flashlight
and probably a lot more and I am so
excited to be able to make custom
shortcuts to do specific things on my
iPhone and Parker ordolani also made a
concept showing what it could look like
when you choose your diff different
customizational options for the action
button when it comes so it's very
exciting now for update number three the
iPhone 15 Pro Models are gonna have
256 gigs of Base storage now this was
speculated and rumored for a while but
now it seems like it's gonna happen for
real and it actually makes sense because
of all of the talk about the price
increases because right now just going
from the regular 128 gig 14 pro to the
256 is a hundred dollars so it makes
sense to increase their price and on top
of that we're also going to be getting a
massive two terabyte option for the
first time on the Pro Models now these
leaks and rumors come from a Korean
blogger ux 1122 who said that he has
information from Apple suppliers and
there's also another user on weibo who
also confirmed this but it could be a
little bit sketchy because we don't know
his track record but to me I I think it
makes sense for a couple of reasons the
Pro Models have been at 128 gigs of Base
storage since the iPhone 12 Pro and now
that the regular 14 models also have 128
gigs it makes sense for the Pro Models
to be differentiated in one more way to
help boost demand for the Pro Models
over the regulars which apple is trying
to do on top of that right now apple is
making crazy good profit margins on the
storage so why not add another two
terabyte option that's going to be
insanely expensive and it's going to
help Apple boost profit margins during
these slow Economic Times and some
people they just buy the craziest option
just because they have the money and
Apple's gonna benefit and that of course
is very important right now because
Apple's just admitted that iPhone sales
demand has been weak recently dropping
year over year in terms of sales and
revenues so right now they're looking
for way ways to boost their profits now
getting into update number four we
recently started getting a lot of
different concept renders showing off
the difference in bezel thickness of the
upcoming iPhone 15 Pro Models compared
to the current 14 pro and previous
models and let me tell you these new
bezels are insane Mark German just
confirmed that they're going to be 1.5
millimeters thick which is basically the
thinnest bezels on any smartphone ever
and looking at them it's shocking how
much of a difference there's going to be
compared to the 11 Pro and keep in mind
that these renders are based on official
cads so they're likely going to be very
accurate and apple is actually using the
same type of lipo technology that they
use for their apple watches to reduce
bezel thickness and they're planning on
doing the same thing for the iPad models
as well which may be why the upcoming
iPad Pro Models are going to have
slightly larger displays within likely
the same chassis which means thinner
bezels and now on to update number five
we actually have some bad news for the
iPhone 15 batteries a few weeks ago the
Twitter or X User RG Cloud s came out
and claimed that the entire iPhone 15
lineup would feature new stacked Battery
Technology which would greatly improve
the battery size of the entire iPhone 15
lineup alongside a bunch of other
benefits from that technology well he
just came out and gave us an update
saying that Apple has apparently delayed
this Tech until the iPhone 16 lineup
probably because Apple feels like they
have enough to make the 15 lineup
enticing enough to upgrade so why not
save some of the good Tech to make sure
that the 16s are another great upgrade
year but the worst part is that he also
said that there were some other leaks
connected to the Battery tech like
faster 40 watt wired charging as well as
20 watt Max safe y wireless charging and
all of that is apparently getting
delayed until that stacked Battery tech
comes next year so with all that said
let's hope we have enough upgrades
especially with Apple's a17 chip to make
it a really good upgrade for the iPhone
15 lineup especially the Pro Models now
here's what I'm personally excited for
you let me know your thoughts Down Below
on which feature you really want to see
but I am so excited for the new titanium
finish because it's going to make the
phone a little bit lighter but I also
think it's going to help reduce
fingerprints and give it a really nice
feel I'm also very excited for the
action button because it's going to be a
lot of fun to play with hopefully it has
really good haptic feedback so you can
just click it all day kind of when
you're trying to find something to do or
you're bored and hopefully it's also
very useful as well with doing shortcuts
or your camera or whatever else I also
really want to see that new rounded Edge
redesign design because it's going to be
more comfortable to hold in your hands
it's going to feel a lot better without
kind of digging into your palm and the
big one is the thin bezels which is
going to be amazing for everyday use
just looking at it all the time watching
videos watching movies it's just going
to be a better experience overall and
finally USBC means that I can finally
ditch all of my lightning cables because
right now I'm using Mac safe for
basically my Apple watch and my air pods
as well so let's finally move over to
USBC you let me know your thoughts and
features down in the comment section
below subscribe right up there and watch
a couple of our great videos over there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]